mais nous vous le disions en titre 30000
places de concert ont été vendus ce
mercredi matin en moins de 15 minutes
c'est la dernière performance en date de
la société de fourang à la Z production
et de son dirigeant Julien Lavergne pour
le prochain live in chambor après Sting
imagine dragons c'est donc David Guetta
qui se produira sur la pelouse du parc
du château de chambor le 29 juin 2024 un
choix qui a visiblement trouvé son
public romain
d'ville à 10h du matin Julie est la
première à avoir ses places physiques
pour le concert de David getetta à
chambor en juin prochain et pour cause
en fait on est on est là depuis 4h du
matin
devant non depuis 4h du matin suspense
quelques minutes plus tard pour Michel
j'espère l'avir parce que une vagine
dragon je n'ai pas eu les places et donc
pour j'ai Sting et je pense avoir celle
de ce spectacle làop suspense et ça
passe je les
ai et je les donne à personne dans les
locaux d'AZ prod se succèd celles et
ceux qui ont échoué à récupérer des
places sur internet sur Internet j suis
allée hier en une minute il y avait plus
rien l d'attente plus rien là ce matin
pareil plus rien heureusement AZ prod a
sa toute petite réserve de billets à
vendre au siège avenu maginau la jauge
est de 30000 spectateurs Julien Lavergne
fondateur de la société de production
considère qu'il aurait pu en vendre le
le flux en fait ça se confirme ce qu'on
a eu sur sing ce qu'on a eu sur magine
on l'a peut-être encore un peu plus sur
David getetta parce que l'événement est
de plus en plus connu rayonne on a
beaucoup plus de demandes qu'on a de
Bill à vendre avec les préventes sur
internet il a fallu comme pour Sting et
imagine dragons une dizaine de minutes
pour booker le concert de David
getetta